oui
[Musique]
évoquons d'abord les révélations
concernant l'entreprise israélienne enzo
dont le spyware a été utilisé par les
saoudiens pour espionner la famille du
journaliste assassiné jamal khashoggi ce
serait aussi utilisé pour espionner des
activistes palestiniens lors des groupes
concernés serait le beesan center for
research and development dont le
directeur ou by albou dit me rejoint
maintenant depuis ramallah en palestine
mbaye merci infiniment d'être avec nous
je sais que le patron d'amazon jeff
bezos a reçu lui aussi un rapport envoyé
aux rapporteurs de l'onu concernant son
propre téléphone qui aurait été piraté
par ce spyware israélien amnesty
international nous dit que vous auriez
été piraté par lui aussi quelle a été
votre réaction quand vous avez appris
que vous étiez infectés qu'est-ce que
c'était mp4 qu'il vous envoie sur bois
de sap
bonjour j'ai bien se marier un choc
d'apprendre simple c'est vraiment
incroyable pour moi j'ai toujours su que
quelqu'un pouvait être en train
d'écouter mais ce type de piratage est
vraiment vicieux
ils peuvent manipuler les données de
votre téléphone ils peuvent en
télécharger les données y applaudit des
données passer des appels envoyer des
messages
dans mon cas ça a été une attaque 0 clic
je ne sais pas ce qu'ils ont envoyée
mais ils ont été capables d'envoyer un
message de messagerie instantanée pour
iphone mon appareil et un iphone
et ils ont pu télécharger dessus ce
vicieux software
c'était en février de cette année et ce
software manipuler mon téléphone en
permanence télécharger des données en
upload et en changer
donc pour moi ça a été vraiment
incroyable
il est très dur n'autorise que la 3g
dans les territoires occupés et la 2g à
gaza donc des photographies de vos
enfants étaient sur le téléphone vous
dites qu'ils peuvent rajouter des
chaussures le téléphone
on encense je veux dire edouard sneijder
a fui à moscou pour sa propre sécurité
après nous avoir appris que soun au
téléphone était sur écoute pourquoi
étiez-vous si surpris or depuis bien sûr
des dénégations d'obama à l'époque où
snowdon nous a dit cela
fait surtout une question de calendrier
parce que vous savez ils ont été en
permanence la cible d'attaqués du
gouvernement israélien ces 10-15
dernières années en tant qu organisation
de la société civile en tant qu
organisation de défense des droits de
l'homme travaillant en territoire
palestinien occupé
et ce type d' attaque vous donne une
idée de jusqu'où ils sont prêts à aller
nous avons découvert l'infiltration de
nos appareils le 16 octobre
évidemment ils ont été immédiatement au
courant que nous avions découvert
l'infection et ils ont essayé de nous
stigmatiser en nous présentant comme une
organisation terroriste afin de
justifier cette vicieuse attaque sur nos
vies privées pendant quasiment les deux
années écoulées
oui à l'heure actuelle vous pouvez être
arrêter n'importe quand puisque le
ministre de la défense benny gantz dit
que vous êtes une organisation
terroriste comme à damir des fun for
children international jeu l'union'' of
palestinian women committee et l'union
of agriculture and more comique 6 l'onu
de toute évidence contre il vous pensez
qu'il est suspicieux que benny gantz qui
est en israël le régulateur de haine et
sow le groupe qui a mis sur écoute
disent que vous êtes une organisation
terroriste juste après la découverte que
vos téléphones étaient piratés
c'est vraiment incroyable pour nous
parce que si vous regardez la
chronologie
c'était mettre la charrue avant les
boeufs c'est dire ok on a fait ça parce
que c'est une organisation terroriste
comment savez vous que nous sommes une
organisation terroriste quelles sont les
données que vous avez quelles sont les
preuves les documents qu'ils ont avancé
en fuite et les médias +972 eddine
intercepte et ont eu accès et ont fait
leur travail de journaliste
d'investigation
et il s'est avéré que c'était un faux
document qu'il n'y avait pas de preuves
concrètes les gouvernements européens
ont eu accès aux documents et après un
examen méticuleux ont conclu qu'ils ne
constituaient pas une preuve concrète
contre notre organisation vous l'avez vu
un dossier de 73 pages que le ministre
irlandais des affaires étrangères a vu
il a dit qu'il n'était pas convaincu
vous avez vu ce dossier et bien après la
fuite il était accessible sur internet
ce document est assez ridicules les
accusations sont absurdes
[Musique]
n'importe quel individu qui résonne de
manière saine se demanderait en quoi
cela constitue des preuves contre notre
organisation
je pense que c'est l'un des problèmes
principaux
pas un seul fait dans ce document n'est
correct et il y à des faits qui l'ont
pris de nos sites internet ou de nos
pages facebook et ces faits ont été
manipulées et interprétée de manière
totalement ridicule
un enfant de 3 ans n'aurait pas
interpréter les choses ainsi
évidemment il ya quelque chose de
symptomatique dans la peur qu'à israël
du front populaire pour la libération de
la palestine ils ont plus peur du pic du
camas désormais
eh bien ils essayent de lier nos
organisations partis palestiniens et
particulièrement le fplp mais nous avons
dit de manière assez ouverte assez
directe que nous sommes des organisation
non partisane
nous travaillons dans le respect des
lois palestinienne nous sommes
enregistrés depuis plus de 30 ans nous
avons de très nombreux audits internes
externes etc nous faisons l'objet de
tant de contrôle est en palestiniens
étant sous-occupation travaillant dans
la société civile étant partenaire
d'organisations internationales et de
pays européens et malgré les contrôles
de l'autorité palestinienne d'israël et
cetera il n'a jamais été possible de
trouver le moindre cas de mauvaise
utilisation d'argent ou le moindre
agissements répréhensibles de la part de
nos organisations donc sortir de nulle
part ainsi et accuser nos organisations
de financer le terrorisme
même leurs faits ne sont pas corrects
ils ont 10 200 millions d'euros sur sept
ans pour les six organisations ce qui
n'est pas correct non plus ce que tout
le monde peut aisément voir
nous sommes un petit centre académique
nous avons sept employés nous publions
des enquêtes notre budget annuel est
d'environ un quart de million de dollars
donc c'est assez petit et la majeure
partie va au chercheur s'est allouée à
des fins de recherche on a compris
ensuite que la raison à l'origine de
cette déclaration du moins nous le
pensons se trouve dans la volonté de
couvrir ces graves violations des droits
de l'homme par m et saut qui est sous
surveillance israélienne benny gantz et
le régulateur de m et saut en israël
donc il y a des liens très étroits entre
nso et le gouvernement israélien oui
n'oublions pas que l'occupation continue
garçon de 13 ans mohamed daddach a reçu
une balle dans le ventre le week-end du
6 novembre à l'est de naplouse et les
violences continuent mais il faut
reconnaître que haine et sow dit avoir
déclaré par le passé ne pas manipuler
lui même ses produits et ne pas être au
courant des détails des individus
surveiller en voyant donc la balle à
benny ganz quand vous parler d'argent
est ce que cela veut dire que vous
utilisez votre téléphone pour parler aux
autorités de l'union européenne ce
qu'ils appliqueraient techniquement que
les israéliens espionne l'union
européenne
j'ai la double nationalité aussi je
parle à l'ambassade des états unis je
parle à des pays européens je parle à
des diplomates jeu par le défenseur des
droits de l'homme en palestine et à
l'étranger donc tous sont compromis tous
ont été espionnées
je ne sais pas combien de personnes ont
été mises en danger par les actions
israéliennes en palestine ou à
l'étranger
et je n'ai vraiment aucune idée quant à
l'étendue des violations de ma vie
privée de celles de ma famille
[Musique]
j'ai une femme et trois jeunes enfants
khaled à 7 ans les jumeaux rassoul et
basses elles en ont cinq
on a fait des selphy ensemble avec mon
téléphone
il y a eu des moments qu'on a partagé en
famille c'est où ma femme et moi
sortions ensemble on a pris aussi les
photos avec ce téléphone donc ça a été
vraiment intrusif
je communique avec mes frères et soeurs
mes avocats aux états unis tu j'aborde
hiver ce sujet avec eux sur ce téléphone
donc tout cela a été violée pensez vous
que l'autorité palestinienne soit au
courant je sais que l'autorité
palestinienne de mahmoud abbas n'a pas
convoquer d'élections dans la foulée du
meurtre de l'activiste palestiniens
nizar ben and hate ils vous ont arrêté
est ce que mahmoud abbas pourrait être
complice dans cette affaire de spyware
pegasus à ce qu'il aurait pu être
victime de chantage de la part d israël
qui aurait mis des informations sur son
téléphone
je ne pense pas que l'autorité
palestinienne soient mieux traitées par
israël que tout autre palestinien
je ne pense pas qu'il donnerait des
secrets pour les opérations des forces
de sécurité israéliennes mais je ne
considère pas qu'ils sont pour autant
exempts de toute responsabilité
nous avons bien sûr étaient dans la rue
depuis le meurtre de mon ami nizar ben
and hate fin juin
il était aussi candidat aux élections
législatives qui ont été annulés
nous avons demandé justice pour niesr
nous avons demandé des changements
démocratiques
nous avons demandé que les forces de
sécurité rendent des comptes pour leurs
violations mais c'est comme ce que
disait omar chakir tout système entre la
rivière et la mère qui contrôle les
palestiniens commet des violations des
droits de l'homme à leur encontre
j'ai actuellement deux affaires qui
attendent dans les tribunaux
palestiniens
et puisque nous avons été désignés
organisation terroriste il pèse sur nous
la menace israélienne d'être arrêté
d'être traduit en justice de voir nos
locaux vandalisés donc nous vivons dans
une réalité assez orwellienne
oui est ce que votre première réaction
je sais qu'il y à la cyber unité
israélienne de 8200 les forces de
l'ordre israéliennes disent qu'il n'y a
pas eu de violations spécifiques dans
une lettre il ya une lettre de lanceurs
d'alert des réservistes qui affirmé
utiliser les données pour extorquer
faire chanter et faire de palestiniens
des collaborateurs qui pensez-vous que
cela affecte les protestations et
l'opposition aux violations par israël
des résolutions du conseil de sécurité
que ce genre de spyware com pegasus
pourrait être utilisée de cette manière
qu be used as well
eh bien je pense qu israël est engagé
dans une vaste opération qui dure depuis
des années une opération d'ingénierie
sociale de la communauté palestinienne
une partie de cette ingénierie sociale
c'est de déterminer quelles sont les
activités qui sont autorisés
quelles sont les activités qui ne sont
pas autorisés quelle société civile
quelle organisation des palestiniens est
autorisée
je pense que ça a lieu depuis des années
et cela inclut le recours à pegasus ce
vicieux et malveillants malware qui
affecte nos téléphones et nos données et
essaye de récupérer toutes les
informations quant à ce que nous faisons
qui est pourtant protégés par la loi
nous sommes des défenseurs des droits de
l'homme nous faisons partie de la
société civile nous travaillons en
respect du droit humanitaire
international du droit international et
des lois palestinienne nous sommes
enregistrés par l'autorité palestinienne
et nous lui soumettons un rapport annuel
nous opérons avec un très important
niveau de gouvernance de responsabilité
et bien sûr de visibilité et de
transparence
et nous avons aussi défier des
organisations israéliennes qui
généralement nous dit femmes comme l'
ong monitor d'avoir des niveaux de
gouvernance et de transparence
équivalent au nôtre
il est cette attaque n'est qu'une des
facettes en tant que palestiniens nous
n'avons aucun droit au regard de
l'occupation israélienne
personne n'est responsable pour les
crimes qui sont commis à notre encontre
qu'il s'agisse de cybercrime ou même si
les crimes étaient dirigées contre des
citoyens ayant la double nationalité
comme moi même ou salah hamouri qui a la
nationalité française et qui n'a plus de
papiers d'identité donc il risque d'être
déportés du pays donc le contexte dans
lequel nous vivons est vraiment fou
dubai al aboudi les israéliens ni
évidemment tout acte malveillant merci
beaucoup merci de même que le groupe
dassault
[Musique]
pour la première fois en témoignage de
première main sur ce qui constituerait
de la torture dans les prisons secrètes
de la cia a été entendue à la cour des
affirmations qui ont été condamnés par
des jurés militaires américains le
détenus considérés de grande importance
madjid kahn est retenue par la cia
depuis 18 ans et il est le seul résident
américain à avoir été détenu au camp
américain de guantanamo
il est condamné à une peine de prison de
26 ans après avoir plaidé coupable de
terrorisme après en arrangements leurs
jours depuis new york 96 hollander
l'avocate de deux détenus de guantanamo
qui joué par jodie foster dans le film
désigné coupable nous avertissons
maintenant que nous allons évoquer le
traitement des prisonniers ce qui peut
heurter la sensibilité des
téléspectateurs
ravi de vous revoir la dernière fois
vous étiez ici avec le réalisateur de
désigné coupable dans lequel joue jodie
foster et qui revenait sur le sort de
mohamedou ould slahi
est toujours ouvert aux non après
l'entrée en jeu de l'administration by
donne
et on va voir ce que l'administration va
décider pour abou zoubaydah qui est un
autre cas que la cour suprême a examiné
et majid khan quiz magic un
oasis kahn a été arrêté
je ne me souviens plus exactement
mais je crois qu'il était très jeune
en fin de compte il a coopéré elle a
opté pour un arrangement les c'était il
ya déjà quelques années
et il a dû attendre longtemps sa
sentence
elle a été prononcée par huit membres de
l'armée
des officiers militaires des officiers
des marines
et à partir de l'arrangement en question
et ce dont il était accusé
il avait l'obligation de le condamner à
un minimum de 25 ans de prison
de 25 fois je ne sais plus le maximum 40
ils ont condamné à 26 ans mais ensuite
à la demande de sa défense ils ont fait
preuve de clémence et 7 des 8 a écrit
une magnifique lettre
disant que cela a constitué une tache
sur l'honneur de l'amérique
ils n'ont pas vraiment dit qu'il avait
été torturé mais que le traitement
qu'ils avaient subis étaient proches de
la torture dans d'autres pays et que ça
n'était pas autorisée aux états unis et
qu'il fallait faire preuve de clémence
c'est une lettre assez incroyable en
saut qui par ailleurs l'arrangement en
question et secret sauf donc on ne sait
pas ce qu'il contient mais ils
pourraient être relâchés
c'est la première fois qu'ils ont
détenus témoignent de torture ils ont
dit que c'était une tâche sur la fibre
morale de la berri à maraka est ce qu on
sait ce que c'est cet officier et je
dois dire qu'il ya un avis contraire je
ne sais pas ce qu'il a pensé de ce
témoignage
de quelle sorte de torture il s'agissait
le mot torture et un terme qu'on emploie
la cour suprême dans le cas d'un loup
zoubaydah et qui a été employé par la
commission du sénat
et bien c'est l'autre chose importante
peut-être encore plus importante de
cette affaire son témoignage a été
publique
de manière générale personne n'a été
autorisé à dire ce qui lui était arrivé
dans les prisons secrètes
ce qu'ils disent ce que mon client m'a
dit abdel rahim al-nachiri est classée
secret ils n'ont jamais eu
l'autorisation de faire part de leurs
sentiments c'est la première fois que
tout le monde a eu l'occasion d'entendre
cela les horribles choses qu'on leur a
faites moi
revenu en arrière dans l'angleterre du
xvième siècle et vous comprendrez en
gros ce qui lui est arrivé absolument
atroce
et c'est ce qui est arrivé aux autres
aussi dans ces prisons secrètes
je veux dire c'était il ya quelques
jours
ce rapport du sénat accuse la cia de
torture illégal en 2014 et il est dit
que plus il coopérait plus ils étaient
torturés
est
ce qu'il dit oui tout cela est horrible
le rapport du sénat rend publique une
partie de ce qui est arrivé à nos
clients mais pas tous
de plus en plus de choses sortent et je
pense qu'il va être de plus en plus
difficile pour le gouvernement des états
unis de garder secret ce qui est arrivé
aux autres à ceux du 11 septembre à mon
client
il ya 26 hommes à guantanamo qui n'ont
jamais été inculpés de quoi que ce soit
qui n'ont pas plaidé coupable
ils sont juste là dans une sorte de
détention permanente qui est un
véritable anathème pour les états unis
pour notre système judiciaire
le président biden tout comme celui dont
il a été vice président barack obama
avait dit qu'il voulait la fermer pensez
vous qu'il a été influencé par le
témoignage par exemple de marilyn down
du us national clandestine service qui
disait je cite il faut que nous fassions
en sorte que la torture n'arrive pas
même aux oreilles des avocats pour
éviter que les terroristes adaptent
leurs techniques d'entraînement si on
parle de madjid cannes il ne s'agit
apparemment que dans petit coursier nous
ne savons pas si la confession d'avoir
été un petit coursier est liée à la
torture évidemment mais qu'est ce que
vous dites de cela c'est le yoyo est
clandestine service je sais que vous ne
pouvez pas en parler il faut que ça
reste secret
c'est ridicule à ce stade ça a toujours
été ridicule
ils se sont cachés derrière ça en
invoquant des sourds des méthodes une
méthode dont on ne pouvait pas leur
parler parce qu'il l'utiliserait
non la torture est illégale en plus
d'être immoral c'est illégal peu importe
les circonstances en respect de tous les
traités
et traiter que les états unis ont signé
la convention de genève la convention
contre la torture
toutes les conventions et c'est dans le
code américain
la torture est illégale on sait peu
importe les circonstances on a dénoncé
cette torture obama a dit on à torturer
quelques gars ce qui m'a semblé être une
manière atroce de présenter les choses
ce sont des gens pas des gars
désormais tout devrait sortir et si ça
peut aider les gens à ne pas écoper de
la peine de mort
et bien tant mieux
parce qu'on a déjà fait tant de mal à
ces gens qu'ils souffrent physiquement
et mentalement tous les jours à cause de
cet horrible torture
ne pensez-vous pas qu'une des raisons
pour garder le secret et peut-être les
ses gonds un amas ouverts c'est que si
tout sortait comme vous le voudriez plus
de 50 prisons secrètes en lituanie en
pologne la pologne qui a été mentionné à
la cour suprême en roumanie ou au maroc
il y en a plus de 50
et bien cela d'énormes implications en
matière de politique étrangère pour les
états unis les gouvernements de ces pays
pourraient être attaqués par leurs
propres peuples pour avoir collaboré à
cette campagne de torture mondiale qui
va comme vous dites à l'encontre de
toutes les conventions du droit
international
bon je ne peux pas parler du moindre
pays où des gens auraient été des coups
non mais vous ne pensez pas que le
département d'état et la maison blanche
se disent qu'ils ne veulent pas que ces
informations soient disponibles pour
cette raison qu'ils n'ont jamais voulu
qu'elle soit disponible le problème
c'est qu'il n'ya jamais eu de fin de la
partie ils ont emmené les gens dans ces
prisons secrètes avec abou zoubaydah
c'est devenu public ils ont dit qu'ils
ne devaient plus voir la lumière du jour
mais ils n'y ont jamais pensé ils ne se
sont jamais demandé ce qui se passerait
si quelqu'un devait découvrir où sont
ces gens est ce qu'il avait comme projet
de tous est tué je n'en sais rien je
pense qu'ils n'y ont jamais pensé quand
ils sont allés à guantanamo ils se sont
dit qu'il n'y aurait jamais de cours
qu'il n'y aurait jamais d'avocats
ils se sont durement battus et ils se
battent encore la constitution des états
unis ne s'applique pas à guantanamo les
prisonniers n'ont pas droit à la
confrontation ce qui est un droit
fondamental aux états unis
ce qu'on peut voir en détail dans le
film jodie foster joue votre rôle êtes
vous surpris après tant d'années à
défendre ces gens qu'à la cour suprême
dans le cas d'abou zoubaydah des avocats
citent au film de ben affleck argot pour
garder les corps de torture de la cia en
pologne
est
ce qu'il vous arrive de rencontrer ses
avocats qui défendent le gouvernement
efficace
j'en ai rencontré et je les rencontre
toujours
je les ai rencontrés dans le cas de moi
mais d'où je les ai rencontrés dans le
cas de al nashiri
vous savez ça reste des gens de la cia
qui croit toujours que mohamedou était
un terroriste
malgré toutes les preuves du contraire
zhang zhong est bien de faire un film
là-dessus
mohamedou en fait un podcast qui
s'appelle 10 american life dans lequel
il parlait avec deux des personnes qui
l'ont interrogé et il continue de croire
ce qu'ils croyaient alors
ils sont juste c'est comme tous les fans
de trump ne veulent pas voir les faits
il y a très peu d'informations dans les
médias traditionnels des pays de l'otan
on trouve dans l'épreuve du khamajeet
kahn que des médecins étaient employés
par les bots americorps
oui
ils étaient obligés d'avoir un médecin
présent à chaque fois qu'ils passaient
quelqu'un ou waterborne
le médecin doit avoir un kit au cas où
il fallait faire une trachéotomie parce
qu'il était en train de noyer quelqu'un
je ne sais pas qui sont ces médecins
mais je crois que ceux qui torturent
souffre
je crois qu'il souffre
et un de ces jours l'un de ses médecins
va sortir et didier j'étais le médecin
qui se trouvait là et regarder des gens
être délibérément noyer jusqu'à présent
on ne sait pas qui ils sont et ils ne
veulent pas qu'on sache qu'ils sont
il y à un élément à ajouter à ce
contexte c'est que de l'argent public
américain a été purement et simplement
utilisé pour financer la torture
en effet il y avait des tracts lâchés du
ciel dans toute la partie sud du
pakistan et au dessus de l'aghanistan
j'en ai un j'en ai une copie qui dit
dénoncé un terroriste gagner 5000 $
c'était écrit en anglais en arabe en
ourdou peut-être aussi
et beaucoup ont été dénoncés ainsi
environ 85% des gens qui sont retrouvés
ont été dénoncés dans ce système en gros
de corruption mise en place par les
états unis je ne sais pas et peut-être
savez vous si ce type de torture a
toujours lieu actuellement s'il ya de
nouveaux cas que vous seriez en train de
défendre je ne l'espère pas je ne
l'espère pas
il y a des forces américaines partout
j'imagine que je devrais vous poser une
question sur la personne n'a plus
torturé du mois selon le rapporteur de
l'onu ici au royaume uni chez julian
assange n'est fait est ce que la prison
de belmarsh est l'équivalent des prisons
secrètes de la cia si on parle du
fondateur de wikileaks
vous pourriez dire ça
il a été longtemps maintenue en
isolement or
l'isolément est considérée comme une
torture si la personne s'y trouve pour
une longue période plus qu'un mois
le rapporteur de l'onu a dit que c'était
une forme de torture
donc est-ce qu'il est torturé comme ces
gens l'ont été est-ce qu'il a été passée
au water board
est ce qu il a été placé dans une cage
avec un insecte dont il a
particulièrement peur
est-ce qu'il a été pendu par les bras
il est aussi le viol si on en prend les
allégations de abou zoubaydah
nashiri aussi
ils ont tous été victimes de
réhydratation rectal ce qui n'est pas un
terme médical
ce n'est pas de la réhydratation
vous savez ils étaient en grève il ne
mangeait pas
ce n'est pas de la réhydratation quand
on envoie du houmous dans le rectum
comme ça c'est du viol c'est de la
sodomie
les outils ont été utilisés dans
certains cas il me semble rien de cela
n'est arrivé à julian assange
tu es de la torture que d'être enfermé
ainsi pour aussi longtemps et seul est
de voir le gouvernement dire de manière
ridicule que ce n'est pas un isolement
puisqu'il a le droit de voir ses avocats
c'est ridicule ridicule
hollander merci
[Musique]